hey guys it is the 9th of March my name
is Jess and here top-mounted in video
games today Tony is now offering
compensation for the PSN outage no not
that one or that other one you know the
one from 2011 yep only five short years
on the publisher are finally sending out
emails with free [ __ ] to make up for the
massive PlayStation Network breach of
2011 weird you probably barely remember
where the service went down for almost a
month and led to a u.s. congressional
hearings Game Informer has reported that
codes for free games are going out now
for people who applied for the
compensation back in January 2015 when
Sony started accepting claims some of
the options Sony are offering include
payment equal to paid wallet balances if
2 bucks or more in PSN or SOE accounts
that have been inactive since the
intrusions a free ps3 or PSP game 3 3
ps3 themes a free three-month
subscription to PlayStation Plus all
portals 50 in SOE station cash Sony may
not be the only ones handing out
compensation as Microsoft are apparently
also considering making up the Xbox Live
downtime over the last couple of months
the service has been experiencing issues
since January which in some cases led to
use as being unable to download or even
access their games four days ago a
reddit thread was posted in the Xbox one
subreddit which was titled
has Microsoft even thought about
compensation for the last two weeks the
thread gained a lot of traction and
eventually called for comment from
xboxes Major Nelson who replied I've
taken some of the more thoughtful
comments and shared them with a few
folks on the Xbox team to make them
aware of this request when I'm back in
the office I'm going to stop by and chat
one-on-one with some folks about this as
well if Microsoft to do offer
compensation hopefully it won't also
take five years to get it to Xbox users
in 2014 Microsoft gave out a free week
of Xbox Live Gold as a make up ethic the
problems that affected Xbox
one on Titan polls launch day finally
the first video for the Star Wars
Knights of the Old Republic remake
called apparel has been revealed and it
looks pretty sweet a YouTube video from
mr. Matty plays shows off a whole bunch
of environments in the game including
lower city Terrace and our spire tank
ahead on Tatooine and upper city Terrace
the game is reportedly in a very early
stage of development where lighting
material and meshes are still being
tweaked and implemented the gameplay
video uses first-person perspective
which is a new addition for the remake
but the original third-person view will
still also be available apparel is being
developed by indie gaming group poem's
Studios who had previously only posted a
slew of screenshots from the upcoming
game let me know in the comments how you
think Sony and Microsoft should be
making up for their network outages you
can add a GameSpot we've got storage on
an uncharted for making off Furies and a
delay for re in the blind forest
definitive edition that is everything I
have for you today but as always let me
know what mattered to you and I will see
you again tomorrow